do you have any doubt I hear you guys
have agreed now whoever wins takes all
the money and that's a lot of money
nearly 10 million dollars have you got
any doubt in your head right now that
you will win and that you may win by
knockout
no I don't I'm confident in my
preparation you know
um anything can happen in a boxing match
but you work to make those things not
happen
um and he just doesn't have the power
the capabilities to to do anything to be
able to defeat me and that's why I'm
willing to put my money where my mouth
is because talk is cheap and and that's
why I'm putting it on the line and
Sunday night you're going to see me
knock this guy out